your choices and your relationships are
probably the number one key indicator of
whether you're going to succeed
financially very difficult to build
wealth and going through six marriages
very difficult to build wealth jumping
from shack up to shack up with different
kids with different dads makes it hard
That's not me picking on somebody or
being judgmental or something like that
all of those things affect money when
you make those choices they harm you and
they set you back there's all kinds of
research that says a couple that gets a
level of education gets married before
they live together has children after
they get married it's amazing what the
research is on that that the family
itself the traditional nuclear family is
a huge indicator of your ability to
build wealth because it's an indicator
of stability and there's teamwork and
there's people pulling together for the
future and I know sometimes things don't
work out and I know people make mistakes
I've made every just about every mistake
you can make I've done every dumb thing
and hurtful bad thing I'm just about I
mean I and so this is not me saying
somebody I'm better than somebody if you
heard that you're just not listening but
there are five things that if you do
them with money while earning an income
over 15 years every time you will build
a level of wealth and one of those
things is quality relationships and
quality choices in relationships but it
you're just American Gigolo young man
and you're just jumping from bed to bed
and a woman as a conquest and you're
just going from female to female and you
just you know everything everything you
see her is she's a task you don't think
that that portion of your warped toxic
sex life doesn't rub off into your
career choices and your financial
choices and your stability and your
ability to keep your word and do things
that are predictable in the marketplace
and you don't think that ends up doesn't
end up affecting your wealth of course
it does of course it does your choices
in your character and the way you live
every part of your life is intertwined
with every other part of your life
that's called a holistic view you don't
get to compartmentalize and say well I'm
this person on Sunday and on Monday
through Friday I'm this other person and
on Saturday night I'm another person you
don't get to decide that you are a
person you're a whole person and all of
these things are connected and they mess
with your future and your ability to win
and it breaks my heart and makes me sad
but I can't how do I talk to you if
you're in that situation and we just met
on the radio 15 seconds ago in order to
give you good instruction when I know
all of that's in the background when I
know until you break your cocaine addict
you know your cocaine habit there is no
freaking way in the world I can help you
with your credit card debt because
there's no such thing at the end of the
day as rich cokeheads I've known a bunch
of them now some of them are rich for a
while they sell their own junk and they
do all this other stuff for a while but
long-term meet them ten years later
they're all broke and broken or dead
all of them I've worked with addicts for
twenty years and it doesn't work out and
it affects your money
hello there's no such thing as a rich
addict you think
agra fee is a wonderful idea and you're
having fun with that well I Got News for
you it's the fastest-growing addiction
in North America today it's destroying
families and futures faster than
anything else we see what's left of the
family and what's left of the finances
when it comes in here for crisis
financial coaching you don't think those
choices have financial and wealth
implications of course they do you live
in the bottom of a bottle are you live
in pursuit of a white line and you don't
think that that's going to make you no
and you're jumping from bed to bed you
don't think that stuff has anything to
do with anything of course it does
because whether people say it out loud
or not they know that when you're
married if you sleep with six other
people if your spouse can't trust you we
know that we can't trust you
now we net may not be that blunt to you
but we all put shields up then you know
everybody knows about George or
everybody knows about Henry and you know
what he doesn't get opportunities and he
doesn't get put in deals you know why
he's not trustworthy he's not worthy of
trust even his freaking spouse can't
trust him your character is an indicator
of your wealth building potential your
ability to do relationships and be
steady and be stable and be sustainable
and be predictable and so when you do
these things that are heartbreaking and
you put yourself in these positions the
only thing you can do after you do that
and I've done dumb things to I'm telling
you I've broken things and you can't put
Humpty Dumpty back together the only
thing you can do is just pray to the
Lord for forgiveness and then say okay
how can I not do that kind of crap
anymore it doesn't work and how can I go
back to solid decision making so that I
can start there to rebuild my life and
the wealth or control of my finances
then flows out of the better
decision-making you got to go back to
solid
ground after you screw up we all do that
make different decisions if you want to
win
that's as loving as I know how to be
this is the Dave Ramsey show
you